Even if this guy's initial speed is
faster, he's faster than mine, but he'll beat me at the top speed no matter how many times
!
I can't read the movements, but I can read the
situation with my own eyes,
so there's
a chance that the tear will kick the ball long,
but the space until the tear catches up with the ball
will be
the weak point.  Disappear,
I won't let you lose your legs I'll
give you a receipt after the assignment
Stop it before the
defense,
no, not yet The
enemy gathered on the left side after breaking through the
defense The defense is on the
opposite side of the space and you can
shoot from anywhere That stage
Gagaru is there
Damn  I can't decide even with this,
but that area is a delicatessen.